angelina jolie opens up about how a
major blind spot in the medical field
has
impacted her children when you have that
many children
they really take care of each other in a
recent article for time
the 46 year old actress interviews
malone mcquenday
a 21 year old medical student who's on a
mission to teach
other aspiring doctors how conditions
and diseases can be present in non-white
patients
in the piece angelina writes that malone
started his project after learning that
quote
almost all the images and data used in
its teachings were based on studies of
white
patients which can lead to quote
misdiagnosis
suffering and even death and the
oscar-winning actress says she's seen
the problem
first hand with her own kids of course
angie and her ex brad pitt
share 19 year old maddox 17 year old pax
16 year old zahara 15 year old shiloh
and 12 year old twins
knox and vivian angelina explains quote
i have children from different
backgrounds
and i know when there was a rash that
everybody got
it looked drastically different
depending on their skin color
but whenever i looked at medical charts
the reference point was always white
skin
the maleficent star also says she
experienced something similar
after her eldest daughter zahara who is
black
had a procedure done last year quote
recently my daughter zahara whom i
adopted from ethiopia
had surgery and afterward a nurse told
me to call them if her skin
turned pink malone says that experiences
like angie's are the kind of thing he
noticed
very early on quote there's a language
and a culture that exists in the medical
profession
because it's been done for so many years
and because we are still doing it so
many years later
it doesn't seem like it's a problem but
malone says angie's experience perfectly
illustrates why it is a problem
quote that's a very problematic
statement for some groups of the
population
because it's just not going to happen in
that way
and if you're unaware you probably won't
call the doctor
back in march 2020 angie opened up about
zahara's surgery in an essay written for
time magazine
revealing that one of her younger
daughters also had hip surgery around
the same time
quote i have watched my daughter's care
for one another
my youngest daughter studied the nurses
with her sister and then assisted the
next time
i saw how all my girls so easily stopped
everything and put each other first
and felt the joy of being of service to
those they love they wrangle me
honestly they're more together zahara is
the most organized in the family
angelina has also been vocal about her
own medical scares
which included undergoing a preventative
double mastectomy in 2013
and having her ovaries and fallopian
tubes removed in 2015
as a preventative measure against cancer
try to rediscover that
that strength within in 2019 she told
harper's bazaar quote
my body has been through a lot over the
past decade
particularly the past four years and i
have both the visible
and invisible scars to show for it
adding quote
life takes many turns sometimes you get
hurt
you see those you love in pain and you
can't be as free and open as your spirit
desires
it's not new or old but i do feel the
blood returning to my body
you